first third nobody down ruiz we
mentioned the only left-hand hitter in
the lineup tonight but he's hitting 257
against left-handers and only 203
against righties and there's a base hit
to score a run
ruiz with the rbi hey scores
all the way to third
is valencia and the orioles got it going
here with three hits to start the second
inning nobody out here in the second
he's throwing 40 pitches yeah they got
him on the ropes one big hit could uh
maybe knock him out
3-2 lined into left field that's a fair
ball into the corner
two runs will score
and the orioles have runners on second
and third and a three-nothing lead two
rbis for cedric mullins quieten at bat
mike boarding boy i'll say it was really
challenged there and finally gets a
pitch he can handle
0-2 and that's cranked into left field
diving ahead chavis makes the play
runner tagging at third the reyes to
throw home and he is out at home plate
so chavis started it with an outstanding
diving play and then guns him down
diving straight forward arguably one of
the toughest plays in baseball come up
with the play and how quickly he gets
back to his feet and throws a strike to
home pretty impressive stuff by javis
see if they have ureas bunning here red
sox playing in on the grass on the
corners
little looper down the right field line
and it's over the head and pass verdugo
into the seats for a ground rule double
and an rbi that's why they didn't have
fun there you go right yeah ramon urias
with an rbi as ruiz comes around to
score boy he turned verdugo around
yeah
rbi opportunity for hancer alberto he's
hit the ball hard 02.
that should get him in
hit well to center field and it's caught
by jackie bradley
the tag in the score
[Applause]
ureas is home and the orioles are on top
five nothing nice job from hancer
alberto yeah orioles have uh obviously
been up and down i think in their
situational game but when they have the
opportunities to do that play that kind
of situational baseball they've got some
guys that can handle the bat
that's hit well
deep center field bradley hustling back
he won't get it it's in the bullpen
home run jose iglesias his second home
run of the year we talked about all his
doubles he's got 15 doubles
but the homers haven't quite been there
well add another one to that list
throughout the oriole fifth and rio ruiz
steps in run it again
hit well to center field
way back and off the wall
austin hayes around third he's headed
home
and rio ruiz continues to scorch the
baseball
three for three with two doubles
and his second rbi of the game urias a
walk and a double for him he's got an
rbi two balls two strikes
up the middle and into center field
ruiz around third heel score
and urease has his second rbi of the
game 1-0 pitch to arroyo
and a ground ball hit the second here's
the throw to the shortstop out on the
first double play
that's a rally killer yes it is and runs
scores but
two men out and a runner at third it's
eight to one jackie crossing the plate
the two two is grounded to the left side
what a diving stop by devers he comes to
his feet throws to first in time to get
iglesias by a step
that was a bang bang play but that was
brilliant from devers diving to his
right leaping up and throwing in time
two down
singled scored a run
in the second inning for the orioles
it's this one well high fly ball
is that fair
it's upstairs and it's gone falayka
with a bomb
up into the monster seats number eight
for pat and the orioles go up 9-1
nicely done the laker the reika strikes
again
up the middle base hit for ryan
montcastle
around third
comes alberto he will score and it's an
rbi
austin hayes three hits last night
two more tonight
that's hit well
and gone
had to wait for the camera to get out
there
what was that was that an ephes pitch or
what he just threw it in there at about
60 miles an hour see you later there's
hancer alberto he was hit by pitches
last time on mike
that's a fair ball
into the corner
that'll get a run home
a couple of them yeah
malayca scores
mario's behind him so bradley will get
to the dish
and that'll do it
down swinging goes bradley orioles a
13-1 some knights are better than others